changement de braquet à présent dans
quelques jours prendra fin le défi du
mois sans voiture lancée par la
métropole tourangelle on a rencontré
barbara habitante de fondettes qui a
joué le jeu avec sa famille expérience
concluante ou plan galère ronan delville
à vélo à pied ou en transports en commun
barbara et ses deux enfants en sont à
trois semaines du défi fil bleu vivre un
mois sans voiture est le principal bien
fait c'est de profiter du trajet
découvre plein de choses sur son trajet
mayer je fais fondettes luynes en vélo
donc j'ai vu la floraison des champs
grâce à la rigueur on peut le voir de la
voiture
les odeurs de l'agrochimie sur les
champs de blé c'est c'est moins chouette
mais j'ai eu une chevrette avec son
jeune qui ont traversé devant moi et
j'ai des amis qui m'ont dit en voiture
elle n'aurait pas fait en fait le vélo
et en plus discret ça permet d'observer
d'autres choses
et puis même des vélos des belles
demeures qui sont sur cette route que je
connais en voiture en mai que je n'ai
pas du tout observé auparavant abandonné
la voiture c'est une idée qui trotte
dans la tête de cette fronde et oise
mais ce que barbara gagne en confort de
trajet elle le perd en agilité
petite surprise après s'est passé les
imprévus c'est un trajet qu'on prévoit
dans un sens si un élément nouveau qui
tombe dans la journée et on est partis
avec des vélos mais le retour ça va être
difficile avec des vélos parce qu'il ya
un élément nouveau une activité en plus
un rendez-vous qui s'interfèrent et puis
et puis retour est un peu plus sportif
que prévu à une semaine de la fin du
défi sans voiture
barbara considère que l'idéal serait de
pouvoir partager une voiture par exemple
avec des habitants de son quartier